I always hear people say that you shouldn't homeschool your kids
because they might not turn out normal.
They might turn out weird.
As if fitting in with the world is the number one priority of parents.
Have you stopped to look around at this world
and at what is normal in this world?
Normal is being anxious. Normal is being depressed.
Normal is being unhealthy.
Normal is being divorced.
Normal is working at a dead end job that you hate.
That is normal. The average age for a child
to first view explicit images and videos online
is 11. That's normal.
So heaven forbid any parent want to deviate from that norm.
Heaven forbid anybody look at that and go,
you know what? I don't want that for my kid.
And of course, even homeschoolers,
anybody can experience those things.
But to pretend like normal is such an amazing thing,
and it's like this high bar that we've set,
it's just a lie. I think so many parents are recognizing this
and realizing that there are far worse things in the world
than your child not being normal.